my name is Alexandra I'm from the
Netherlands I used to work in the press
office until very recently and I worked
a lot with our trainees because I was
responsible for social media and I
always needed extra hands especially
during summits so normally I would have
let's say 2 to 3 trainees helping me but
then during a summit it could be up to
10 I think what makes a great trainee is
a willingness to learn really an
openness happy to try new things happy
to take on extra work
I like trainees who are not afraid to to
step out of their comfort zone and to
try things even though they haven't done
them before and I think that's also what
makes a traineeship a great learning
experience is that you get to do stuff
that you might not be familiar with
stuff that you didn't do it University
and that way you can actually as a
trainee get some really valuable
experience that is useful to you in the
rest of your career what I've seen
happen to quite a few trainees is that
they came here may be relatively
inexperienced or used to working in an
academic setting and then they left with
a much greater sense of what it's like
to you know work in an office context
work also in in a European context and
even in a in a political context because
here at the council we are so close to
European politics this is where even
leaders meet and I've seen Chinese
really grow in that sense maybe we
become more professional or just faster
in completing their tasks and also some
of them have become more confident I
really love how enthusiastic our
trainees are I do remember occasions
when they were maybe a bit too
enthusiastic our current trainees belong
to the generation of Millennials of
digital natives so for them taking a
selfie is normal and sometimes they have
to be reminded that you can't always
take a selfie everywhere and not all
world leaders might appreciate you
taking a selfie with them but other than
that it's yeah it's pretty great working
with these young people